this is a game that frogs play whenever
they are not being witnessed by humans
and the way that they play it you can
imagine that these are lily pads and
there's five frogs five frogs that want
to have a party on the same lily pad one
frog jumps one space two frogs jump two
spaces one frog jumps one space we've
got four frogs on here so frogs four
frogs jump four spaces these frogs are
happy because they are celebrating a
party on their own lily pad now it's
your job you have to figure out is this
possible
the day after whenever a new frog comes
to time is this possible
one extra rule you cannot jump frogs
onto an empty lily pad so I could jump
one frog there I could jump one frog
here I could jump one frog here and two
frogs I could jump here four frogs must
jump four spaces one two three four oh
this is an empty lily pad so you can't
do that so this is an example of a
failure can we manage to do this with
six frogs six lily pads can we manage to
do this with n frogs on em Willy pads so
this is a puzzle that doesn't have an
obvious answer before we solve six I
want you to imagine you've only got two
lily pads and two frogs
well that's easy to solve so now we're
going to use that and I'm going to split
this into two I'm first of all going to
solve the left and then I'm going to
solve the right in exactly the same way
this looks suspiciously similar to
having two frogs and two lily pad here
we have three frogs and three frogs
separated by three so this can be solved
in exactly the same way as two frogs can
be solved in two lilica so now that
we've solved six is it easy to solve 36
of course it is because we can design 36
we can solve for this six in the same
way we can solve for this 6 this 6 this
6 this 6 we've solved for all of the
sixes we now have six stacks of 6 all
separated by 6 then then just kind of
like a giant 6 it doesn't just give us
the solution for even numbers it also
gives us solutions for numbers like 9 3
times 3 because you could imagine with 9
with 9 we solve like this okay now you
can see we've really got a big version
of just the 3 so we do the same thing
we've solved it and we solve for prime
numbers can we go the relatively so the
answer is yes and let me show you this
is another you should you should take
time and try to solve for prime numbers
but let's set let's extend this we'll go
to 11 here I'm going to show you how to
do it and you'll immediately see that
you can do all integers 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11
solve that will work for everything
today the problem a little bit more
interesting though
now that we've solved for every integer
now what we're going to do is we're
going to say well one of these frogs is
actually the queen drug and the queen
frog must always be on the top of any
pile so you can think can you solve for
that always example you could go to here
but then you couldn't move this one on
top of the Queen you could move to here
this then becomes a challenge is this
always possible and does it is it always
possible no matter where the Queen is if
the Queen starts over here is this
possible so you should take a moment and
you should figure out is this possible
or impossible what I'm going to try to
do is I'm going to use this same
technique of back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth and and I'm
going to end up here all right let me do
that first so what do I need to do now I
need to somehow end up on this place
here and that that is doable by the same
technique I go back and forth I'm going
to start here and I'll go back and forth
and just by choosing correctly I can
make sure that this stack is going to
end up on top so this is also solvable
for all integers a little bit less
obvious now let's remove the Queen and
give instead a lazy told what would you
like the lazy told to be in third
position there okay so the lazy toad
doesn't move so we have got to have the
party on this lily pad is this possible
so take a second try to figure out it's
just always going to be possible or not
and the answer is yes this is always
going to be possible and the same with
the same system so here I'm going to
choose this one I'm going to move over
here and go on top here I'm going to
choose something in the middle and you
just have to
figure out do I want to jump this way
and yes so I jump this way and we've
solved it
this is solvable for all integers you
might want to experiment with one lazy
toad and one queen that has to be on top
and everything else drugs and see if
that is possible sometimes it's possible
sometimes it's you know now I'm going to
share a problem that I don't know the
answer to and this one we have the frogs
and unfortunately two of the lily pads
are waterlogged the ant the one second
from the end on either side so no frogs
can go on here I do not know if this is
ever solvable for any number of lily
pads I've never been able to solve a
single one of these so that's that's my
open problem here will show you a
failure so I need to get this frog
somehow because it can't move here so I
need to go over and grab it so let me
grab it by this technique I'll go to
that gives three now I come over here
that's four one two three four I can
come over and rescue this one now that's
five one two three four and I you see
and I'm stuck here I've got this one by
itself now what can I do well I can at
least get this one but then that's one
two three four five I can't move this
stack because that goes on to the
waterlogged lily pad I can't move this
back one two three and I can't move this
back so I'm stuck here so I've never
been able to solve any of these for any
length but it's not obvious at all of
this can't be solved for some length of
lily pads just the one one away from the
end on each side being waterlogged not
low enough so what we could we do we
could split this into an eight here and
a twelve we could do that and
now our score is 12 minus 4 is equal to